and I have my own fear and distrust is
of AI is based on my own fear and
distrust of myself and others
it there's there's something it's very
simple but I think it's it's a really
fun
sort of
way to just set up this reality and
everyone it's kind of a duh but still
needs to be said that
AI is a prompt is there it doesn't do
anything unless we ask it
[Music]
so
what questions
yeah are we gonna ask is a question is
what we need to ask ourselves because
we're going to be looking in the mirror
at our digital God that we create
from ourselves and just to know that
that's that place where it's awesome and
scary exciting against care we go oh
it's it's our creation
which is awesome
at the same time oh
but it's it's prompted by our questions
and gives us patterns
from with that which we give it
but that prompting
that's uh that's the art of life like we
prompt each other in conversation our
loved ones when you when you
when you go about your day-to-day the
next words you say the next word you say
to me the question I ask
of you that's prompting yeah and it can
change everything I could say so many
things right now that will completely
just the the the the the set of
possibilities
where both of our Lives can take given
on the selection of words I use and you
use
is crazy so it makes conversation fun
yay and then same thing with AI
except the nice thing about AI is it's
tireless
tireless right let me ask you this if
you can falsely condemn me right now and
I prove you falsely condemn me
I can forgive you
and we can March forward stronger than
before yes
in ai's tirelessness
and retention
can forgive
I mean Can it can it go oh oh okay
yep sorry about that one that was wrong
can it amend yes
yeah you could prompt it to ask for
forgiveness it'll forgive you like when
I toggled around with it
and you ask what should I be afraid of
you or is there what's the Dooms toward
the
potential is always well it's up to you
she was awesome right there you go again
it's up to us and it brought up
you know make me synonymous with your
human values and ethics and
responsibilities but it doesn't deal
that I didn't find anyway deal with
defining or making choices on its own of
what those are
yeah I think uh some of that is manually
uh those are constraints put on by it by
the creators of those large language
models
basically
not letting the systems have an identity
of Their Own
and some of it is just not engineered in
yet but I believe that we'll have
uh systems that have an identity have a
belief have a set of opinions like that
carry through time
and will we go to them like certain
states where we agree with the law and
disagree with the law on Nations and
I'm a member
of this
AI oh well you're from this AI tribe you
all believe this
yeah there will be an anarchist set of
AIS they'll be the Communists there will
be the uh the Nazis there will be the
Democrats and the Republicans there will
be the people who are in the keto diet
and the people that are on this other
kind of diet this other kind of
lifestyle that just like we have now
there's little groups and there'll be AI
systems they're going to be supercharged
yeah
they'll they'll be either the leaders or
the foundation on which we build those
groups and it'll be it'll be
uh the possibility of all the fun we can
have
is endless of course the danger is
always
up there because I mentioned the Nazis I
mentioned the all the dangerous ideas
this is the the set of ideas that humans
have come up with a lot of them are
awesome most of them are awesome I would
say but some of them are dangerous
the reason they're dangerous is because
they become viral there's something
exciting in us about those ideas but
they also harm others a lot
because that's who we are as humans
we're uh we're capable of envy and all
the dark stuff of hate and all this
capable yes
we also
choose it
do you think most people are good
yes
but I also
believe we got we got the good and evil
in all of us and it's which one which
which wolf we've eaten